[Music]
liyan in your head fighting goes to my
head hey what's up guys my name is a
discerner and welcome to another video
so this is kind of like man I keep
tripping over stuff this is ridiculous
welcome to one of these videos this is
kind of like a new style that I'm
bringing to my channel where I'm going
to basically it's kind of like a vlog
style thing where I go out because I do
actually end up traveling a lot and go
into cool places is where I kind of go
out and then I'm going to be talking
about specific things and answering
questions that you guys kind of provide
questions like that I get a lot and
don't really have the chance to answer
in other videos because they're so
technical and they're like tutorials so
let me know what you think of this new
format because it still is new this is
like my second vlog I think it's pretty
cool
I think it's something new something
different hopefully you guys agree with
me so today we're out here in the wood
if you can call them woods because I
mean I am this is Australia and woods a
kind of questionable in Australia so to
speak I love to go to Europe and get go
to someone's hat I am going to Europe
later this year and about a month or so
so definitely got to be some cool
footage there but anyway the question
that I want to answer today is one is
probably the biggest question that I get
just ever this question honestly is the
most asked question on all social media
platforms that I just get all the time
and that question is what is the trick
to learning programming how do I learn
programming quickly and today I'm going
to tell you that trick because the trick
is actually extremely simple and I'm not
going to make this video ten minutes
long and start kind of leading up to
this I'm just going to tell you straight
I'm going to tell you how it is practice
so many people just want to learn
programming quickly whether that be
because they want to make games or they
want to make websites or they want to
make apps for mobile devices they just
want to learn programming as soon as
quickly as possible so they can just
start releasing these games and apps and
all that stuff and so they try and find
videos online or books or courses or
anything they'll just teach them
programming quickly because they think
that I just need to find the right
course and then that'll teach me exactly
how it needs to get taught and also I do
agree that some courses in general up
much better than others and will teach
you quickly because they're teaching you
stuff that you actually need to know not
kind of superficial level stuff there's
no trick to it you just have to get down
and do the work and if you actually
start doing that then you will learn
much much faster that being said the
recommended way to learn a language is
going to depend on that language and
also what you want to do with language
but I honestly recommend buying a book
because books are incredible resources
if you go to anyone's like office if you
go to any workplace like for example I
work at EA games and at EA games we've
got an entire library of books why
because books are really really precious
people underestimate them now in the
video age I do make videos and I try to
make them as high-quality as I can if
you guys don't know I do have a C++
series on this channel which I'm trying
to make as in-depth and it's complete
and as good as possible link so that
will be in the description below but
overall books are such a precious
resource because books of things that
authors actually put time into books are
things that people actually sell and
make money off of them and authors make
a living from selling books and because
of that the quality is much much higher
you know you can't you won't find like
some teenager who's just started
programming just making it right like
just writing a book and putting out that
whereas you will find videos of that on
YouTube because YouTube is a free
platform so people do underestimate
ebooks with books
in a lot of ways can teach you much
better than any videos and I've actually
linked my favorite books for a number of
languages below so it'll be a link in
the description so you guys can go by
them if you so choose to but just a
consideration give books a shot and
those books are my favorites anyway
getting back to it that the one trick to
learning programming is practice you
need to actually start writing code I
really like comparing this to learning a
musical instrument for example you're
going to learn how to play a guitar or
piano you can watch so many videos
online you can read so many books but
unless you actually pick up the
instrument and you start playing it you
cannot going to get anywhere right if I
watch a hundred videos on how to play a
guitar riff but I never touch a guitar
when I finally do touch a guitar I'm not
going to be able to play that riff am i
no way I need you need to actually you
need to actually practice it you need to
get the muscle memory in programming is
exactly the same I don't know why people
can't understand that programming is
exactly the same as learning any other
skill you need to actually practice so
my recommendation is that you stop this
video you stop watching videos of people
programming you open whatever IDE or
text editor you want to be using you and
you just start programming just give it
a shot
stop this video right now after liking
it stop this video right now and just
start programming start writing code if
you get stuck guess what you can Google
whatever your question may be right if I
was building a website and I didn't know
how to Center a text element on the
screen I can Google that I can be like
hey Google how do i how do I send her a
text element in the screen in CSS or an
HTML or whatever it is that you're using
that's how you learn you start actually
you take on a project and you start
writing code if you keep watching videos
if you keep thinking I don't know enough
to start working on this game that I've
always wanted to you're never going to
know enough because you know what I've
been working in the professional
industry and core technology at AAA for
two and a half years and I still feel
like I don't know anywhere near enough
to be doing the stuff that I am doing
but guess what when you actually start
doing it when you start implementing
that huge feature that you've been
assigned to do you get stuff done you
learn you ask questions and you get
stuff done so that's it that's the trick
you to actually start programming
practice
it start experimenting with things
that's another really important point
tweak things if you've read it tutorial
online and you've copied all that code
try and change it try and see what
happens if you're trying to learn C++
change the compiler settings and see
what happens maybe changing optimization
settings look at the generated assembly
code just experiment with things people
back in the day when they were working
on cars for example didn't have the
internet they didn't have all these
resources they might have lived in some
remote village where there wasn't even a
library and how did they learn how did
they learn to modify their car or fix
their car they experimented they opened
the hood they started changing parts
they started taking stuff out and seeing
what each part did that is what you need
to do you need to just seriously try
this I'm being 100% serious right now
try this just go offline for a few days
and see what you can actually do just
using your IDE or just using what you
already know and when you reach a
problem don't Google it right for once
in your life don't Google your way out
of something try and actually fix it
yourself
it doesn't matter how bad your solution
is but when I started programming I came
up with with just such incredibly
complex solutions to problems that
required one line of code to actually do
what I wanted them to do because I
didn't know about it but the point is I
tried doing stuff like that once once
you've got your thing working then maybe
you can go research what the correct way
or what the optimal way to do what you
were trying to do is but just give it a
shot yourself experiment play around
with the code you will learn so much you
just have to trust me on this and give
it a shot so that's it it's pretty
simple that's really all there is to it
you just need to actually put time into
it and you'll get good alright anyway
that's pretty much all I had to say
today really really nice place that I'm
in right now in the forest see I'm going
to be posting some of these photos to
Instagram link will be in the
description below make sure that you
follow me there if you want to see those
photos and also one other thing that
I've been doing which is pretty cool I
think on Instagram as I've been using
the Instagram story feature to actually
just update people with what I'm doing
today and how I'm actually filming
videos so my future videos I actually
edit and put up shots of that onto my
Instagram story so you can catch them
pretty exclusive content there
it obviously expires after a day so make
sure that you follow me
because there's some pretty sweet stuff
going on on Instagram anyway hope you
guys enjoyed this style of videos again
I'm hoping to do a lot more of these in
the future if you have any suggestions
for future videos just leave the client
below and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]